I'm like why am i giving birth to the
Green Goblin for Halloween this year a
Burger King has decided to make a
whopper with a black bun and we're here
today to try it out I've heard that the
Halloween whopper makes you poop time
Green part of being young and you know
having fun is just eating things and
seeing what they do to your poop I'm
gonna wrap this look at that oh there
she is this is like dark
this is obsidian as what's it they took
a hockey puck and cut it in half and
then stuck sesame seeds on it it smells
like a normal cheeseburger just I don't
know black it's weird it looks like it
it's rotten but it feels alright there
we go it's fine it's not like amazing
it's not terrible feels like a huge
burger I feel like it kind of like
enhances their whole Charbroil thing
tastes a little odd tastes like there's
some weird there's something weird going
on big fan writer George off Burger King
is this a ploy to get more black people
to come to your restaurant the green
poop aspect definitely made me want to
try this more because I'm a sick weirdo
I am not so nervous about how it's gonna
come out I'm actually kind of excited to
see I'm kind of concerned about my poop
turning green but uh that's a that's a
future me problem so we'll get there
when that happens
woke up this morning went to my bathroom
sat down did my business and it was a
very grain like highlighter grain the
poop happened my poop was green it's
it's such an unnatural color it like
looks like a joke I would say it was
kind of like a an olive green bordering
on emerald uh-huh I think it was like
underwhelming a little bit it's
literally this color I think life would
be better if not only if everyone pooped
green but if people if people poop
different colors based on what they ate
I would definitely eat it again that was
this morning so we'll see what this
afternoon this evening has in for me